une dizaine de jeunes joueurs un seul
objectif intégrer la future académie de
rugby a plaisir à la rentrée prochaine
c'est rugbyman ont bravé les chaleurs de
ce mercredi 9 juin pour se soumettre à
une journée de détection organisée par
le club pour reconnaître les meilleurs
des tests de haut niveau ont été mises
en place alors là il y aura plusieurs
plusieurs séquences ayant une séquence
physique avec des tests de vitesse et
ensuite tu auras des séquences de jeu de
manipulation voilà qu'on puisse observer
la technique et le sens tactique des
joueurs quoi pendant le jeu et des
choses qu'on voit très très vite
effectivement après il ya des choses il
faut qu'on mette en place un peu un peu
de jeu de mouvement pour voir un peu les
qualités de deux des joueurs et des
joueuses
ces tests vont permettre de sélectionner
des joueurs de 16 à 23 ans du
département des yvelines au total ils
seront une vingtaine de joueurs et
joueuses intégré cette structure au mois
de septembre elle sera encadrée par le
club et promet plus d'heures de rugby
aux sportifs on va travailler toute la
semaine en fait on va leur proposer un
planning hebdomadaire avec 2 5 à 12
heures en plus de rugby individuelles en
plus de leur séance collective
une formule qui a séduit les joueurs
présents sur place c'est une opportunité
pour en faire plus et être avec les amis
y a plus d'accompagnement pense que ça
peut amener un autre niveau canon que
auquel on joue déjà
ça peut être une bonne opportunité je
trouve pour me perfectionner au rugby on
peut toujours s'améliorer et puis
l'accompagnement à l'air d'être plutôt
sympa comme ça nous a déjà été un peu
expliqué donc c'est peut être une bonne
une bonne expérience
si j'ai détecté à un patient et a hâte
de voir la suite à une nouvelle journée
de détection est programmée ce samedi 12
juin à 14 heures au stade robert barran
de plaisir